et rossi de nouveau dimanche de
mobilisation pour les partisans d'alexei
and have any qui appellent à sa
libération touche à sa fin rappel il est
incarcéré pour ne pas avoir respecté les
conditions de sa peine de prison avec
sursis
les mobilisations sont non autorisée par
les autorités
dimanche dernier la police russe a
procédé à plusieurs arrestations et
aujourd'hui what she can par
l'intermédiaire de son nouveau
secrétaire d'état a condamné les
tactiques brutales je signe de la russie
contre les manifestants d'opposition ou
secours dénonce de son côté d'
ingérences grossières de washington et
manifestants se sont dirigés vers la
prison dans laquelle est détenu alexeï
navalni le point sur la situation avec
un autre correspondant depuis moscou
antoine karouf à aucun moment les
organisateurs du rassemblement de ce
samedi n'ont réussi à faire ce qu'ils
souhaitaient à savoir réunir un maximum
de gens à un endroit donné
le plan initial était de rassembler un
maximum de personnes au niveau de la
place de la loubianka symboliquement
devant le siège du fsb mais voilà les
forces de police ont complètement bouclé
le périmètre et fait fermer les stations
de métro qui aurait permis de s'y rendre
en conséquence les organisateurs via
leur canal instagram dédiés ont proposé
ont désigné plusieurs autres endroits
afin de s'y rassembler mais à chaque
fois le même schéma les forces de police
qui boucle le périmètre et qui ferme la
station de métro la plus proche résultat
pas de grandes pas de grand
rassemblement statique comme c'était le
cas la semaine dernière mais plutôt un
cortège de sans doute plusieurs milliers
de personnes qui déambulent dans le
centre de la capitale
bien sûr cela n'a pas empêché des
arrestations d'avoir lieu encore une
fois sûrement plusieurs centaines
d'arrestations
mardi ce sera au tour d'alexis navalni
de passer devant le juge pour les
violation de sa période de probation on
saura donc mardi 6 à peine de prison
avec sursis ou tout du moins une partie
de cette peine avec sursis sera commuer
ou non en peine de prison ferme